[Musik]
dort wird ihnen präsentiert vom toyota
yaris dem kleinsten vollhybrid
[Musik]
die kulisse dieses filmes ist das
jugendheim erlenhof es liegt am rand der
gemeinde reinach im kanton baselland
zwei jahre lang dauerten die
dreharbeiten
entstanden ist ein fehlen dreier
jugendlicher auf ihrem weg zur
selbstfindung
[Musik]
das mini segment uhren von merle es ist
ein glück okay es sind vielleicht größer
sie das dass sie dann zimmer burschen
sträußchen zustimmt also wenn jetzt der
sache mit ihnen machen bild und zufall
war es eigentlich nur gemütlich sind
das ist weder der anfang noch das ende
von kevins geschichte
es ist sommer 2015
der 16 jährige kevin macht im erlenhof
ein praktikum in der landwirtschaft ins
heim kam er weil seine eltern
überfordert waren halt sehr viel
durchsetzte comic kolleg als man viel
salat konzern emi hat uns wieder einmal
gewalt aber auch aktiv und somit da man
jetzt eigentlich eine abschließen
momentan
zum jugendheim gehört doch ein sucht
betrieb mit schottischen rindern
wer sich einem rind nähert muss ruhig
bleiben sonst wird das tier nervös es
braucht selbstüberwindung vertrauen und
einfühlungsvermögen deshalb sind tiere
auch therapeutisch wirksam
nebst seinem landwirtschafts praktikum
macht kevin ihm heim seinen
schulabschluss
doch den unterricht bei lehrer stefan
odermatt schwänzt er oft kurz vor den
sommerferien kommt es zur aussprache
macht für mich wenig sind ich bin zu dem
schluss von jahres gültig interessiert
wenig provokativ zeit nicht und du
willst doch sein problem seite es wird
zu viel spielt das heißt ich hätte dafür
blockieren verfahren habe weil er kauft
ihnen des schülers ist und das immer
darauf einmal zwei stunden lang und
jetzt wahrscheinlich wird das auto
einzeln oder auch 5000 verzichten der
das für mehr viel mit momentan mit spiel
und sehr weltlich der mittägliche
frieren wenn es zu wied gut weiß dass
rafa nieder eskalieren
also eigentlich muss ist sofort die
aussagen will ich wieder eskaliert also
wenn ihr seid ja machen wir das mir
heute besucht und mir war das mittel
miteinander um gar um audio themen ried
ist bearbeitet
dank kevin ist aber bereit sich von
einem anderen lehrer unterrichten zu
lassen
aber nur zwei stunden pro woche wenn ich
jeden quantitativ bearbeitet die alte
verhaltens wie sony person event läuft
gerade blüht zur sind schlägereien sind
zb sich es bald potenzial da was auch
liebesleid und das will ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt steigt wieder für alle
der erlenhof erstreckt sich über 30
hektaren
aber was da hier das hat nicht unbedingt
welche das drehbuch ist auch dominik
lebt in jugendheimen und macht bei
walter schule ein praktikum in der
landwirtschaft mit dem stehen und was
sie was von wasser sie verbraucht ich
war das quasi mittellos sei hier die
pflanze im boden was sagen was das ist
historischer boden mit berichtete dass
mitarbeiter wurde wo der junge frauen
denn wenn der politische wille ist und
sein schwager ist häufig das thema ja
sowieso scheiße oder und wenn ich sehe
dass der dominik aber noch oberhofer und
spaßtag ex sandy dass man die richtigen
arbeite hart daran wieder zusammen
steckt für sie im rathaus gemacht jetzt
natürlich weiß kleine dinge
[Applaus]
bis heute mit dem meister-team mittwoch
und der millimeter groß und gut zu
platzieren
haupt zu stehen
geschafft mit walter schluss natürliche
autorität kommt der 16-jährige gut klar
das trifft bei ihm nicht auf alle
menschen zu
dominique hatte einen streit mit einem
anderen heimbewohner
deshalb sind die beiden zu einem
gemeinsamen kletterkurs verknurrt worden
die aktion leitet erlebnispädagoge
reinhard england war so begriff
schlagwort gute kommunikation sage ich
jetzt mal noch dazu man muss sich gut
miteinander verständigen damit das
glaubt die sache das miteinander
durchexerzieren an rücksicht nehmen
werde jetzt miteinander
machst du eigentlich streng gesetzestreu
nicht mehr laufen gut der schlacht
zwischen coswig tor nach es hat den
öffentlichen schulen klappt stress mit
leder mit mit schüler im unterricht nur
maschine
wir möchten die ich sage ich sie
eigentlich mittleren burg mutige
menschen laufen die lage also besser mit
ihr als mit dem anteil jedoch sagt
alicia sie wird sprachen einem nimmt man
kann mit ihnen auch wenn er mit einer
knödler dass das ist dass sie mit der
ich hoffe somit beruf geholt
aber so eine chance sie ist auch absolut
ende juni 2015 geht kevins praktikum zu
ende
danach kann er bei walter schlupp eine
zweijährige lehre als landwirt mit
kompetenznachweis machen der lehrmeister
ermahnt aber den jugendlichen an seinen
schwächen zu arbeiten aber im beruf wie
der berufsleben was habe weiß ich aber
wichtig das schulhaus notwendig gemacht
ich habe das maximum das man die drachen
eingeschrieben ist indes muss aber nicht
mit zum beispiel nur griffe das machte
muss man keineswegs so dass man schon
feststeht und muss der text könne lasse
oder messen was das gehört natürlich
auch dazu
kevin verspricht die schulbank auch
während seiner lehrzeit zu drücken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nach den sommerferien im kleinen klassen
unterricht bei giancarlo januzi seine
schüler kevin und dominik stahl glas und
der station mal drunter steht vielleicht
sogar verliert nimmst an was durchaus
zusammenfasst ist es normal und jetzt
holt doch verdammen die wichtigste sache
durch die ohren ist natürlich 345 seien
zudem ist das gerät
geben gemessen an dieser fünf minuten
vor schluss noch ein neues bringt ist
täglich gibt es 81 kilo mit ich gebe den
letzten wochen immer halten jetzt.de
oder texte märkte russische religiös
jetzt und jetzt was braucht so bitter
das nicht ablenken und stand xx oder
wirklich und friedhelm brockhausen
s-bahn scharf machen was brauche ich
denn das motto wie möglich halten dass
kunst auch jedoch beweg dich mit mir du
bist du bist du gleich und wird so für
nächsten sich tick anders ich mich
anderen seite gaben die schulter oder
ist also so wie heute morgen offen ist
für die in ordnung dass du
initialisieren noch nicht mit kuschel
sondern weil sie lernen dass sie
ständig effektiv überträger von uns
erwachsenen also muss ich das mache ich
mach das sieht man eine jahre so manches
fast überall in unserer klasse so
unterhält einfach weniger widerstand um
mehr bereitschaft das heißt nächstes
jahr viel besser aber die wildschweine
sind spürbar zu mehr kraft stimmig du in
psychologie stimmig wobei mir die jungs
allergene normalen wohl das nette falls
jahren fällig im jugendheim gibt es zwar
klare regeln aber repression ist nicht
teil des erziehungs konzeptes eine
rundum betreuung im erlenhof kostet die
öffentliche hand 14.000 franken
monatlich
dieser betrag beinhaltet betreutes
wohnen schule und beruflicher ausbildung
heimbewohnerin andrea macht den
kompetenznachweis für hauswirtschaft sie
arbeitet nur teilzeit aus
gesundheitlichen gründen
ich hab's irische erkrankungen deshalb
ist es nicht immer einfach mit mass
grund von borderline und alles mit einer
stimme ich schwanke ich muss reicht von
medikamenten zum können normal sie und
geschaufelt und alles unterstützt mich
damit und verständnis auch wenn ich mal
schlechter da kann und den mag ich an
der schranke schon immer bestandteil für
die maximal muss brauche also angefangen
hat chance sieht das christkind dass
sich herr afrika oft vor dem ende des
schul- und msn ski und vor
jetzt sind die jahr ist diagnose
festgestellt wurde wort allein ihre
stimmungsschwankungen sind enorm das
leben wollte sie sich auch schon nehmen
wie schaut es fällt sehr schnell
ich habe mich nirgends aber halt des
neuanfangs sich auf ihn schießt kannst
viel chaos sieht man jetzt den augen
lilos werte hat die heim hat sich auch
wenn ich kein kontakt kann ich habe mich
als geborgen gefühlt
andrea sagt der erlenhof seife sie zur
heimat geworden seit sie hier wohne habe
sie ihr drogenproblem im griff
von mia ist das haben auch so gesagt
dass ich am tage mehr als gedacht haben
dass man überhaupt training morgen bei
zug statt
und jetzt zeigt sich dass sich auf
einige monate reduziert und hat
unterstützt kann sich auch viele
fortschritte gemacht auch durch therapie
und nicht freiwillig drei monaten alles
haben jetzt kann ihn wirklich jetzt
arbeiten dabei und bin stabil
im werkunterricht bearbeiten dominierte
uns die anderen jugendlichen das thema
widerstand
sie ist nun fast sie das macht und total
ist sowohl stimmen und sanierte gebäude
im erlenhof leben insgesamt 80 junge
menschen bevor dominik ins heim kam
wohnte er bei seiner mutter yvonne giger
ist geschieden und alleinerziehend rund
um die uhr betreut sie ihren zweiten
sohn
der 14 jährige ist mehrfach behindert
und leidet an autismus sharif zu
schützen die sich mit schokolade eine
farce - blatter
die betreuung von roche kostet viel
energie ihre nerven habe sie aber wegen
dominik verloren sagt sie also sehr spät
ein schlimmes ich eine figur die
situation und den du gehst du bist nicht
sagen
späth sowie und ist für die wichtigen
systeme pixeln oder folie also nicht sie
sondern konnte nicht mehr laufen
deshalb hat die 49 jährige den kontakt
zu dominik abgebrochen
ich sehe zwar willkommen es eltern
einfach enttäuscht das ist aber
eigentlich besteht dass sie die nummer
gekommen bin sagt er
was für das es aber dazu bereit oder
nicht ist mir unmöglich wenn es mal
gewesen ist und wächst sie beschrieben
stunde stimmt und software jakob in das
bistro einsamkeit überhaupt nicht was
und wenn ich ehrlich bin ich froh dass
ich bin froh das ist nicht was ich
glaube so benutzen ist
ende 2015 lebt kevin bereits mehr als
ein jahr lang im heim seine lehre als
landwirt gefällt ihm vor allem die
arbeit mit tieren zu menschen scheint
der 17-jährige weniger vertrauen zu
haben
seine betreuer wissen nicht viel über
ihn jugendpsychiater gerhard [ __ ]
versucht den jugendlichen zu öffnen mit
dabei ist auch kevins bezugsperson der
sozialpädagoge philippe egger er macht
jetzt hier auch einschätzt und was für
dich die beste therapie und so weiter
und ist dann wieder nur mit
halbwahrheiten arbeiten muss oder
hochstimmung fragmenten da kannst du
kein gescheites bild ja auch in deiner
zeit in seiner partei was passiert ist
und haben zu viel zugelassen
es kommt jetzt viel und den konsum
das ist und bereit sein zimmer dass ich
jetzt nicht nach
das klar stoffes jeden fall es wird
daheim bei kevins mutter nadya
muchenberger hat zwei söhne mit dem
älteren sei alles gut gelaufen erzählt
indes habe es mit kevin oft streit
gegeben mein herzlicher sowie die immer
gefordert dass er wegen wir die probleme
hat der schul- und damit der schlägerei
das ist am 2 11 2 11
was meinen sie stolz der grund das ganz
große das kevins vater roland
muchenberger ist geschäftsführer einer
spenglerei die scheidung habe seinen
sohn schon geprägt räumt er ein
doch die probleme handele sich der
jugendliche vor allem aufgrund seines
charakters ein
ich glaube dass der journalist auf einer
häufig oder immer wieder unter falscher
lied antritt ist aufmerksamkeit will
flug sich ziehe
das ist der hauptgrund wirklichkeit das
saarland nach einer saline vaduz sitzen
unter den roma den normal läuft und ich
glaube das ist ein moslem stabilem
einsatzbereitschaft
naja so übertrieben will zeigen wie
cross safaris und es wird alles extrem
im materialraum machen
mehr sage ich glaub ich kaum zehn
minuten oft heraus zu trinken kaufen
drei zigaretten bevor sie irgendwelche
explosionen und jo aus sich schon mal
nach verteilung sie und ist das remis
ander hof ist das für sie also soll
nachhinein muss ich sagen es ruhiger
erstmals war das haus und beruhigen und
auch es ihnen ist auch
für sie war mache ich hoffe haben immer
eine ruhige größte hole mir ist es dank
und wieder stelle von mobile spätere bis
o also von daher ist schon doch
[Musik]
ich lass mich für manchester auf sich
genommen
kevin hat einen krise ich meine wenn ich
stress wird trainer sagt ja alles sie
wohne ich dann quer oder wie gesagt dass
ich auf die entscheid drauf wenn ich
jetzt nicht vor daher weitermachen dann
wird sich so brach er auf rache
ja wenn sie mit mach ist daheim genieße
er mehr freiheiten sagt er aber einfach
so aus dem heim austreten darf kevin
nicht ein konflikt scheint sich
anzubahnen
andrea fühlt sich unwohl die gespenster
ihrer kindheit plagen sie ja ich behalte
allem schuld sie was passiert ist so
egal was schlecht läuft für mich ich bin
schuld sie hatte sich demnach also von
formularen oder wie hat sich ein
bisschen andere zum teil gesehen ich
mich noch aus aber das hat er selbst
sitzt du aber meistens deutlich mehr so
leicht man schon haben wir nachgedacht
wie die anderen mit malen und dichten
versucht andrea sich selber aufzurichten
doch die traumatischen erlebnisse bringt
sie nicht los ja ich an zwei cent
heitkamm mit großeltern und andere
jugendliche brach knox wurde und alles
und auch geschlagen wurde vor
jugendliche eltern und großeltern
schlimmes passiert ein traummann über
dass sie nicht öffentlich sprechen mag
[Musik]
die sonne mag die luft kaum erwärmen an
diesem tag
anfangs des jahres 2016 frostig ist doch
das klima im sitzungszimmer des
ehrenhofs dominik und seine mutter haben
sich zu einer aussprache getroffen
doch nach kurzer zeit verlässt yvonne
giger die runde nur uploader und beraube
trotz hieß es man hatte damals und ich
bin bereit wie tethering also sie sind
wie wärs doch nicht aber jetzt gespräche
sind dort sind suchen 150 zu bienen
ruhig hana santoni zu unserer zeit nicht
da sie
die stuhl durch die wüste und das
problem ist immer keine von sie wirklich
etwas gerade problem ist und die museums
hat dazu gehe ich will langsam wirklich
einen schritt zu machen weil jedes mal
wenn ich es probiert doch und zwar in
den usa
[Musik]
ich sehe das so die rätsel warum macht
das körperliche schmerz tut weniger wird
psychische schmerz ende januar 2016 ist
kevin nicht mehr im heim anzutreffen
nach einem vorfall mit einem anderen
jugendlichen kehrte er nicht mehr zurück
sozialarbeiter rené neuenschwander weiß
mehr
kevin wurde durch einen messerstich
leicht verletzt es gehe ihm bereits
besser nun hat er inzwischen 17 jährige
aber ein problem mit der
jugendanwaltschaft kurz yoga wenn der
masse staffelstab kunde hätte herr klima
tuner im verrohrt und die hat der
weltgeschichte zählt das liebevolle
worte sieger von meiner mama und yoga
hat aber nach innen in denen auch gerade
relativ schnell gefunden das zu kevin
und sind die kollegen der über geschäfte
zähler
und dass die geschichte nicht stimmt die
kennt jetzt war das verfahren am hals
wäre für die justiz das ist ein weiterer
punkt war im kevin 777 in die geschichte
zurück führte das aufklärt und rufend
html hof möchte abbrachen und unter
vorlauf und der ganze geschichten ziehen
roland muchenberger ist froh dass sein
sohn nicht schwer verletzt wurde
allerdings bleibt die geschichte nebulös
kevin sagt nur vage was geschehen war
der anblick macht den etat als mass film
entnahme biete sich macht mit der trophy
nachbarn irrt den uni spital
und schlimme schon auf tv shows auf 6
gegen city kellerdecke das weiß ja
keiner
kevin wollte dominik decken sie waren es
die sich gegenseitig das spaß kämpfe
geliefert hatten
so schlimm wäre was machst du das es ist
vergangenes umgegangen ist und gut danke
mittelbuchen also vielleicht hätten sich
macht sich gerade die trikolore ich
meine wird die jedem scheiß wohnlich
gemacht gedanklich darauf konnte der
ganztag nutze machen können wir wirklich
geschafft wodurch dann glaubt lang bin
dass ich danach wieder eingenommen
zum tragen ja nicht ich denke nicht
darüber nach und so missraten das quälen
muss er bis vertrag in dem trüben tagen
werde ich mir die capra kluge alex
keplerstadt dominik und kevin werden von
der jugendanwaltschaft wegen
falschaussage zu je vier tagen
sozialdienst verurteilt
zwei wochen später ist kevin noch immer
nicht in den erlenhof zurückgekehrt er
will einfach nicht mehr im jugendheim
wohnung ein standort gespräch mit allen
beteiligten soll klarheit schaffen
der pädagogische leiter des heims marcel
schiller ist anwesend
die mutter ist gekommen der vater auch
mit dabei sind lehrmeister
sozialpädagoge und sozialarbeiter
nur einer fehlt unentschuldigt kevin
doch das will ein foto
ich hoffe dass ich mit an bord was macht
trete ich bei outlook antwort weißt du
was ich dass eine tortur hier sind
wahrscheinlich geschneidert haben
sie hatten traurig kevin hallo ich habe
mich nicht so das schaufenster ist macht
ihn bestimmt über dunkel berlin
nein ich trage ein begriff nein erst
gefühl also dass jetzt alles wieder ok
wien
ich meine du musst auch okay aber hier
führt dass ich das wirklich dank ok also
gut model mirja boes sahen das hätte ich
vorher sehen können den neuen schon hat
dass er kommt mit erinnern zu gesprächen
mit ihnen haben danken so einer großen
runde wenn alle zusammen kommen und
sagen hey was aus mir ist aber dass
gesagt dass auch die nächste arbeit
haben es aber ganz anders haben eben
wieder sicherstellen dass das ist
captain dass ich das ist geld da ja also
der kelvin damals möglichen als dass ich
dabei eine stadt für alle extremisten
werden dass die calvin aus dem ruder
läuft und das und das und das machen wir
danken den hätte wirklich eine schlechte
prognose das wird dazu führen dass das
die kabine
[Musik]
andrea soll selbstständiger werden
deshalb hat ihr sozialpädagogin melanie
kropp renter im auftrag des ehrenhofs
eine wohnung gemietet
aber andrea muss ihren cannabiskonsum
auf ein minimum beschränken
sie wird regelmäßig getestet dank immer
zum thema urinproben da wäre die
erwartung dass einmal wöchentlich eine
urinprobe abgeben und akzeptiert werden
moment jetzt von uns die ubs weiterhin
bis zum wert von maximal 50
das heißt die galerie art dass sie oft
nur noch toleriert wird eigentlich der
ober wert von 50 bei der andrea weil die
borderline erkrankung die andrea hat
häufig in zusammenhang steht auch mit
einem suchtmittelkonsum und jetzt und
andrea häufig thc in der vergangenheit
genutzt hat um sie vielleicht hat
schneiden zu müssen oder nicht selbst
verletzen zu müssen so und für uns dann
das überwogen hat gegenüber der null
toleranz und dann starten die show
spielen wenn wir dieses jahr die
situation haben dass wir uns sorgen
würden dann kann es sein dass wir
einfach aktiv werden
psychiatrie oder oder psychologe
hinzuziehen immer in absprache mit der
wohngruppe dann darf ich dich bitten
dann kommt noch meine unterschrift
drunter
bei giancarlo januzi ist dominik wegen
seiner neigung zu gewalt in therapie er
hatte nach dem vorfall mit kevin eine
weitere auseinandersetzung mit einem
jugendlichen januzi ist nebst seiner
funktion als lehrer auch gewalt
therapeut ich nie wirklich so vida loca
familie kommen wird wenn ich tanzen
durch sie benutzt muss stress kim
clijsters ergo oder löst das turus wird
diese durch schicken wo ich liebe wie
ist die situation derzeit der schon
letzte woche oder vorfall basiertes oder
man die war vorfall was ethisch wo es zu
meiner komplex ist eskaliert
jetzt eskaliert will das ist sich einig
mit demselben namen welche macht die
ganze doppelte größe und alles
vorstellen wie bröckelt hatte herrscht
heißt durchschnitt gebracht oder has
been kurz fotografiert er aber es liegt
aber im normalfall passiert halt wenn er
läuft nicht zurück so einfach ist das
bild das ich nico wie tabak und
mitmachen aber möchte ist also reagieren
eigentlich nicht ob man das ist ein ganz
spezielles weil michael so rasch dass
sich alle die nicht als star
was weiß ich weil da wodurch stadt läuft
unbedingt jetzt eine schlägerei fokus
und sobald nicht blutig see oder
schwenken hoffe mich wie im blutrausch
puppenstuben und das wundert mich bei
dir weil du auch station in der wohnung
und da hast du an ganz andere
möglichkeiten wenn ihr gezeugt in den
ersten tagen des märz 2016 ist kevin
wieder zurückgekehrt in den erlenhof bei
walter schlupp erscheint kevin zwar
wieder zur arbeit doch er weigert sich
standhaft sein zimmer im jugendheim zu
beziehen sonst schmeiße er seine lehre
drohte er noch immer dass ich die große
chance kevin
das portal ist nach einem biss in der
hand und wenn man die jetzt das ganze
geld der schlossstraße der bischof der
strooss wahrscheinlich oder nicht aber
apple beraten
im falle aber machen muss stoß ein
weiteres standort gespräch steht an
diesmal mit kevin es geht hart auf hart
damit man sich mal vorstellen er es
fertig gemahlen sich auf mehrere
aufkleber ist also wenn jetzt drauf sein
bloß mit denen die drei wohl nicht so
fliege stellen verschoben oder deutsch
die lotter prozent über dem durchschnitt
einfach mal vorbeischauen boxer in den
usa bereits wieder deutlich dass boost
titel zu werden ist unsicher da bin ich
meist ein gelübde für technisches fett
an der schulpolitik das beschreibt leben
ebenso wie offen stand dass wenn alle
stricke reißen und abbott und eskaliert
in einem auto das der slowakisch und der
musik der redlichkeit und übrigens keine
meetings wird ich ganz klar sagen die
beamten bis jetzt wer muss mittelmark
hat es ist nicht so dass man das machen
wir drei jungs kenne keinen muss mit
lernten etwas
kevin zieht ab sofort seine mutter aber
wenigstens berichte so seine lehre nicht
ab der jugendliche wollte hochzeit
findet das nun mit dem film auch
kommerzielle ego sondern mitwirke wo wo
kommen nun gespielt
die wiederum wird halten begleite und
bilder zeigen zur verantwortung ziehen
und sagen sie ihrem sohn poesie in
sabine gut im herbst 2016 begleitet
sozialpädagogin melanie pop renter
andrea in ihre eigene wohnung die 18
jährige verlässt das jugendheim voller
hoffnung und freude sie ist kein
einzelfall
eine deutsche studie bestätigt dass
jugendliche nach ihrer zeit im heim
psychisch stabiler sind und dem leben
bestehen können deshalb verursachen sie
der gesellschaft schlussendlich dreimal
weniger kosten
die miete ihres ein zimmer appartements
von monatlich 800 franken übernimmt der
erlenhof ebenso die kosten für die möbel
ja bis jetzt hörte die kreative wird sie
glauben dass ich alles müssen und das
gibt mir natürlich die griff mir und mit
dem käse auch das hat unruhe auf
dominiks wohngruppe zu beginn des
frühlings 2017
er ist aus dem heim ausgerissen das
pädagogenteam ist besorgt wohngruppen
leiter matthias bürger telefoniert mit
dominiques mutter hat sich wohl mit der
mutter in verbindung setzt hat angegeben
dass er das ein gedanke der ambivalenzen
von jetzt selber bemühungen zu
unternehmen sich ein zu weise in
psychologisch psychiatrische einrichtung
bis hin zu suizidgedanken jetzt wirklich
nicht in panik verfallen
ganz klar sondern jetzt einfach für
moment warte auf jeden fall im
kontinuierlich kontakt mit der mutter
bleiben
das team versucht mehrmals dominique auf
seinem handy zu erreichen ohne erfolg
daheim bei dominiks mutter yvonne giga
weder sie noch die betreuer im
jugendheim wissen wo dominik steckt
danke für die information kurz zuvor
erhielt sie einen während anruf ihres
sohnes ich glaube dass gott zu mehr ruhm
mehrheit der bankkarte cities probierte
so gewagt mit mir wieder kontakt auf
aber die halt märkte dem day funksprüche
mit der situation wie goalie hausmutter
mit der situation um eine stimmen holte
dank vorgriff medikamenten ihn an und
was schämen wenn man die wüste wohnen
ist und was macht was wäre dass sie das
gebiet frage das ist wirklich gut und
ich hatte kommen ich sehr gern als ist
schon sich hinter ihm probieren so gut
ist kurz unterstützung verdient als sie
daheim bei nadia muchenberger seit kevin
wie dabei erlebt hängt der haussegen oft
schief gerade eben verließ ihr sohn
genervt das haus weiter druck den sich
vietoris mal exklusiv bis bestimmt
wieder wird eine richterin befragt
respektlos fragt einfach donath und die
pflegeassistentin ist arbeitslos und auf
stellensuche
auch gesundheitliche probleme plagen sie
sie hat mit sich selbst genug zu tun
aber nicht nur auf das setzte zum
überholen und eine stimme für mila dann
nicht wenn sportlich muss auch wirklich
wieder um werke ihrem taktstock nun und
kleine kindergartenkinder trust auf
geordnet
kevin ist in letzter zeit oft krank und
fehlt bei der arbeit nun geht er zum
arzt
das machte druck und stadthalle
was ist schlimmer zweiter werden und
wird wohl kurz vorm großen kopf bei
schwindel keine sehstörungen nicht die
hirnerschütterung zog sich bei einem
faustkampf zu der arzt stellt ihm ein
zeugnis aus dass der jugendliche seinem
lehrmeister geben wird kevin will ihm
auch gestehen dass er wieder eine
schlägerei hatte die kennlinie frieden
so eine blöde sicher ist ja meine bei
meinungsverschiedenheiten sind überlegt
einfach davor zu nahe kommen gar nicht
wert
ende juni geht es eine zweijährige
lehrzeit als landwirt mit kompetenz
nachweis zu ende
zurzeit ist der 18-jährige auf
stellensuche ist es nicht schwer die
zeiten kevin minister fordert dass es
auch nicht überschätzt wie sina eine
sitze seine fähigkeiten aber nie wo die
stiege und es ist aber ganz offen ich
probiere ich probiere immer optimistisch
sie wartend sich für das eigentlich
jedes jahr schließen im erlenhof zehn
jugendliche ihre lehrzeit erfolgreich ab
dominik wurde auf der straße von der
polizei aufgegriffen und zurückgebracht
ins heim im keller seiner wohngruppe
lässt er seinen frust ab
es ist richtig dass die busy wie tät die
der inhaber die sanität war nicht schön
damit könnte junge was ich es dann
werden und zwar nicht nur die hülle
gern würde er im erlenhof einer lehre
als landwirt machen
doch sein zustand ist noch sehr labil
macht er das auge natürlich sehr schön
auf die ungewissheit wie deswegen
anschlussleitungen die kliniken machen
oder kompletter wieder trotzdem lieber
jetzt clean air als freudschen
sunnitisch dominik wird nun vorerst
einmal psychiatrisch abgeklärt
das jugendheim hält ihm die lehrstelle
offen bei der 18 jährigen andrea geht es
weiterhin aufwärts
sie beendet ihr praktikum und beginnt
nach den sommerferien im erlenhof mit
einer dreijährigen lehre das für mich
ein großer schritt will ich jahrelang
glaube nicht so klappt
isabelle und mit traum aufgeben
sozialpädagogin zweiter will ich dann
kann ich schaffe nicht erreichen
und jetzt bin ich doch ein schrittmacher
3 und dann im sommer als fachfrau
gesellschaft oder staaten
das ist weder der anfang noch das ende
der geschichte von jungen menschen im
erlenhof das heim in reinach ist für
jugendliche bloß eine zwischenstation
auf ihrem lebensweg finden möchten sie
alle dasselbe einen platz in der
gesellschaft
[Musik]
dort wurde ihm präsentiert vom toyota
yaris dem kleinsten vollhybrid
[Musik]